for now we're talking politics with a
we're talking food actually with a side
of politics we're to begin this hour
with more of the countdown to election
day now just a week away a little bit
over a week and our series three meals
is back on the road sampling some local
food and also sampling the minds of
Voters to hear what's going on what are
they counting on this morning we're
going to take you to Wisconsin better
known these days as the Battleground
state of Wisconsin where Adriana Diaz
sat down for her three males with voters
who could be critical in determining the
balance of power in Congress Wisconsin
by the way only state that went for
President Biden two years ago were a
Republican senator is now up for
re-election
as day breaks over Lake Michigan most of
Kenosha Wisconsin is still asleep good
morning but Frank's a standalone Diner
that's almost 100 years old is
overflowing this is a place where you
have to know everybody's name it's like
cheers
[Laughter]
college students Mary Travis and Alex
Laton came for breakfast and a break
from The Barrage of political ads what
happened when you see all these the
right to abortion shouldn't be up for
debate in Wisconsin an abortion ban from
the 1800s is now in effect yeah is that
top of mind yeah it is I would really
like to vote for politicians that you
know want to overturn that as opposed to
well if they said it was fine in the
1800s and why should we ever change laws
abortion is one of the top issues for
Democrats in the critical Senate race
Republicans here care more about the
economy they want to keep Republican
Senator Ron Johnson in office but he's
neck and neck with Democratic Challenger
Mandela Barnes the current lieutenant
governor but you can't tell the story of
Kenosha without talking about 2020.
violent protests followed the shooting
by police of a black man Jacob Blake
during those days of unrest a young
white man Kyle Rittenhouse shot and
killed two people I didn't do anything
wrong he said it was self-defense and
was recently acquitted after the
violence of this city Kenosha really
swung red do you think people are still
there honestly I'm not sure I think it's
a little bit of both we might not be so
red we might be uh purple grandmother
Mary mccutey has voted for both parties
do you know you're voting for yes would
you like to share no okay
what matters to you this midterm
election
quality for all just really makes me
angry when I think about how people are
so prejudiced against someone else
because of their beliefs or because of
their color of their skin that's just
stupidity Prejudice recently landed in
the mailbox at Frank's when owner Kevin
Irvin received a letter from a group of
white supremacists so I think it's just
one more incidence of how this country
is how split it is it saddens us our son
is African-American my granddaughter is
African-American you know it's just
foreign
not what I want for her for everyone we
spoke to this election is personal and
everyone we asked here said they plan to
vote but what about the rest of the
state
[Music]
we headed upshore for lunch in
Wisconsin's most populous city Milwaukee
county is also home to roughly 70
percent of Wisconsin's black population
and LSA in 2016 Hillary Clinton lost
Wisconsin due in part to low black
turnout here that turnout declined again
in 2020 so the effort to get out the
black vote is on
and it's fueled by caffeine and coffee
makes you black located in a former Bank
building it's Park Cafe okay thank you
part political pit stop I don't miss an
election vote I early vote you early
vote yeah Shaquilla Morrison here with
her friend Farina Brooks says Milwaukee
needs help and fast it's a long distance
homicides Less jobs poverty no resources
the community organizer and bus driver
hope local elections Drive change in a
zip code known as one of the nation's
most incarcerated and impoverished
Morrison who's also a poll worker says
the turnout she's already seen this year
has been low I need my people to come
vote
don't you say with a smile
[Music]
to fully understand Wisconsin you have
to leave the cities
where the changing leaves reflect a
changing electorate to give you an idea
of how purple this state is 23 counties
flipped from Obama to Trump and two
counties flipped back to Biden one of
them is Sauk County this is home to more
than 1900 working Farms
we stopped in at Sky High Fruit Farm
where you can fill up on apples donuts
and dinner
that's like this thing Brian and
Stephanie Schmidt own a landscaping
business this County alone has flipped
Republicans
and then everybody to talk to the change
are two and every time you talk to them
some people you know what I mean is that
true yeah you'll hear some of that
pretty much yeah they're focused on the
economy I mean I guess we lean more a
little Republican a little bit you know
with stuff but because Democrat you know
kind of had control and it kind of went
the wrong way everything did you know
the economy and then like the borders
and then crime you know everything's
gotten a little soft by the barrels we
met Aaron Halverson and his wife Aaron
Halverson or as her friends call them
the errands what are the issues that
that really matter to you guys first and
foremost
affordable health care for everybody
women's rights to choose and definitely
quality education Sauk County went for
Obama then went for Trump and then went
for Biden do you invest sense of which
way it's going to go yeah based on the
signs I see driving around it's yeah it
looks like a talk away yeah right a
toss-up that's typical in this purple
States politics for CBS mornings Adriana
Diaz Wisconsin
[Music]
I always enjoy these segments so much
because number one voters want to talk
yeah they do you guys have both seen
they want to talk they have lots to say
and we have our own three meals coming
out we sure do ahead I was in Georgia I
was in Florida yeah and it's just
interesting to hear what's important to
people yeah and that's what this all
comes down to right and having the food
on the table is disarming it really is
it breaks things up have a bite think
about it reflect it's kind of hard to
lie when you're eating some good food
that's true all right